In this section, we will continue going over the steps for using the custom body workflow
by executing step 3 and 4.
In the previous section, we executed step 1, where we positioned and scaled the head
rig, and then executed step 2, where we updated the DNA using the new neutral mesh and aligned
the head and body skeletons.
The step 3 portion of the script will check the body and head skin weights, and step 4
will merge the body and head skin weights.
So let's return to Maya and execute step 3.
Back inside of Maya, step 3 will check and validate the body and head skin weights.
This will check if the skin weight influences on the neck region only contain influences
that are supported by the standard metahuman head rig DNA description.
In the script editor, I will scroll down here to step 3.
I will select these lines here from 183 to 185 and execute this.
If the check fails, we will get this warning pop up.
This notifies us that the head area contains skin weight influences not supported by the
standard DNA description, and that gaps may appear at the seam during deformation.
It recommends that we modify the body skin weights so that only influences included in
the metahuman head rig are used in this region.
Select I will fix this.
Now the body skin weights that need to be adjusted are going to be highlighted.
I will go up here and select this tool in order to isolate the highlighted sections.
Now with the selected, I will go up here to the top left and change this to rigging.
Next go up here to skin and then select paint skin weights and click on this to open up
the options.
Now I'm going to move this over here.
In the script editor, over here, it has listed the names of the unsupported influences.
I will copy the first one which is for the right upper arm.
In the paint skin weight tool settings, I will paste the name in the search option to
locate the selection and select it.
Next I want to adjust the values.
For the opacity, I want to ensure that this is set to 1 and for the value, I want to ensure
this is set to 0.
And now I can select flood.
In the viewport, I will click on the highlighted selection and now I will repeat this for the
other section.
I'm going to go to the script editor and copy the name of the other unsupported influence
and then paste it in the search option to locate the selection.
I'm going to leave everything the same and select flood again and then click on the highlighted
selection in the viewport.
Now before we continue, let's do a quick review of the steps we just went through.
Step 3 validates the skin weights on the head and body.
It will check whether the skin weight influences on the neck region only contain influences
that can be described in the DNA file.
To check the body and head skin weights, select line 183 to 185 and execute it.
After a few moments, if the check fails, a pop-up will appear letting us know that we
need to modify the body skin weights so that only influences included in the metahuman
head rig are used in this region.
Otherwise, this may cause gaps to appear at the seam during deformation.
We will need to modify the combined body rig skin weights in this case.
Once we see the warning pop up and click on I will fix this, the skin weight sections
on the combined body rig that need to be modified will be highlighted.
We will need to remove the skin weight values associated with these selected vertices.
To do this, isolate the selection, then go to skin and then select the paint skin weights
and open up the skin weight tool settings.
In the script editor, copy the name of the unsupported influence and then in the paint
skin weight tool setting, paste the name in the search option to locate the selection.
Ensure that opacity is set to 1, value is set to 0 and then select flood and click on
the selection.
Then repeat these steps for the other selection.
With the combined body rig skin weights adjusted, we can now rerun the skin weight check.
So let's return to Maya and continue with step 3.
Back in Maya, now that we have modified the body skin weights, we can rerun the validation.
Select this section again and execute it.
Now we will see a pop up letting us know that no issues were found and that the skin weight
influence is complete.
Now before we move on to step 4, since we have updated the skin weights on the combined
body, we want to copy the skin weights to the body only mesh as that will be the mesh
that will be brought into Unreal Engine.
To transfer the updated skin weights from the combined body to the separated body mesh,
first make the separated body visible.
We will need to change over to rigging mode.
And now select the combined mesh and then select the separated body mesh, go up here
to skin and then select copy skin weights and click on this to open up the options.
In the skin options, check the settings, the default settings are fine and now select
apply.
I'm going to get out of this mode and now I want to export this as an FBX.
To do this, select the separated body mesh and then select the root, go to file and choose
export selection.
Now before we move on, let's do a quick review of what we just covered.
In the script editor, we can rerun the body and head skin weights validation and if no
issues are found, a notification will appear letting us know that the check is complete.
Now since the skin weights on the combined body have been updated, we will want the body
only mesh to also be updated as that is the body we will be bringing into Unreal Engine.
To transfer the updated skin weights from the combined body to the separated body, we will
need to change over to rigging mode.
Then select the combined body mesh and then the separated body mesh, then go to skin and
select copy skin weights and open up the options.
Select the settings and then select apply.
From there, select the separated body mesh and root and export the selection as an FBX.
Now let's return to Maya and execute step 4.
Back inside of Maya, now that we have validated the head and body skin weights and saved the
separated body and skeleton as an FBX, we can now run step 4 which will merge the body
and head skin weights.
I will select step 4 from line 191 to 197 and execute this.
Step 4 will create new skin weights using the neck falloff weight blend mask that is
located in the custom body integration workflow folder.
This process writes new skin weights back into the DNA file and once it's complete,
the DNA will be added to the export folder.
Now this process may take up to 8 or 9 minutes to complete.
I have sped up the recording for this process and left the script editor visible so that
you can see what this will look like.
As we wait for this to finish, let's do a quick review of step 4.
Once the head and body skin weights have been validated, step 4 creates new skin weights
using the neck falloff weight blend mask.
Select all of step 4 from line 191 to 197 and execute it.
This process writes the new skin weights to the DNA file and it may take several minutes
to complete.
Now that's it for this section.
In the next section we will wrap up this workflow by executing step 5.